good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking welcome to basic
fighter maneuvers
as briefed today's exercise is dog
fighting guns only no missiles
we do not go below the hard deck of 5
000 feet
working as a team you have to shoot me
down or else or else what sir
or else i shoot back
if i shoot either one of you down you
both lose
this guy needs an ego check we'll see
that
so what should he put some skin in the
game what do you have in mind whoever
gets shot down first has to do 200
push-ups guys
that's a lot of push-ups well uh they
don't call it an exercise for nothing
sir you got yourself a deal gentlemen
flight's on let's turn and burn
fanboy you see him nothing on the radar
up ahead he must be somewhere behind us
where's your wingman
booster where are you i got you back i'm
coming hang in there hang in there hurry
up man hurry up
break it right
rooster just saved your life fellas
but it's gonna cost him
not this time old man
let's go
[Music]
should be us down there
but it's not
and now you know a little something
about rooster
oh wow hey hold that time back down till
we get back brother all right
[Music]
it was all funny games that's up he
wasn't it damn say phoenix now how's
about we tell everybody bob stands for
something other than robert i mean don't
take the bait bob want to know why we
call him hangman all right i got it baby
on board
going that's why we call him hangman
he'll always hang you out to drive
leaving your wingman there's a strategy
i haven't seen in a while he called you
a man phoenix you gonna take that so
long as he doesn't call you a man talk
to me bob where's maverick jesus his
nose is already coming around
get off me hangman for all you folks at
home this is how you bury a fossil all
right hangman time to teach you a lesson
you're out phoenix son of a [ __ ]
i'll give you that
[Music]
how close am i phoenix
i'm dead [ __ ] what's he in the
afterlife back man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
lights out coyote copy kill yeah
[Music]
say rooster mind if i ask you a personal
question would it matter if i did
so what's the story with you and
maverick it seems like he's got you a
little rattle it's none of your business
no where the hell is he been here the
whole time
holy [ __ ]
you see me now
come on let's get it over with
fights on
what is with these two
all right you put us here how are you
gonna get yourself out
you can bail out anytime
how low you want to go rooster i can go
as low as you sir and then saying
something
what's pastor's past for both of us
you'd like to believe that wouldn't you
our next five thousand feet fell if
you're running out of room
your strategy is about to run us into
the ground what's your move
altitude altitude
altitude
altitude
altitude
altitude
altitude
pull up
it's too low
too late had your chance
that's a kill
not enough
damn it
same old rooster
[Music]
go see hondo about your push-ups
all right that's enough
talk to me bob we are 12 seconds late on
target we got to move we got to move
copy try to stay with me
huh
wait who's that
blue team you've been spotted [ __ ] is
maverick what the hell is he doing here
i'm abandoned on course to intercept
blue team what are you gonna do he's 20
miles left 10 o'clock 700 knots closure
your call what do you want to do
continue we're close stay on target
swinging around to the north
standby for pop-up be ready on that
laser bob copy i'm on it
blue team bandit is still closing
popping now
talk to me bob where's maverick he's
five miles out he's coming fast
target's in sight where's my laser bob
did i did i it's no good sorry i can't
get locked we're out of time i'm
dropping blind
damn it missed
that's tone garbage got mr
coyote come in coyote level wings
oh my god he's in g-luck
he's gonna burn in i'm going after him
oh come on give me time give me tone can
be toned
step out of it coyote come on come on
come on coyote come on come on
coyote you okay you okay
i'm okay
i'm good
good
good
that's enough for today
that was close
too close
bird strike first strike
phoenix left engines on fire climbing
throttling back shutting off fuel the
left engine extinguishing fire
right engine is out it's still spinning
try to restart it
it's on fire don't startling us
oh my god
i can't control it we're going down here
you can't save it he checked ejected
you